and during today's press briefing well
Fox White House correspondent our own
peter Ducey confronted the White House
Press Secretary Karine Jean Pierre over
this strange blunder and as per usual
she refused to directly answer Peter's
question take a look how was President
Biden ever going to convince the three4
of Voters who are worried about his
physical and mental health that he is
okay even though in Las Vegas he told a
story about recently talking to a French
president who died in 1996 I'm not going
to go down that rabbit hole with you sir
Rabbit Hole he said he talked to Minon
you saw the president in Vegas in
California you've seen the president in
South Carolina you saw him in M Michigan
I'll just leave it there our very own
peter tusi is joining us now with more
um it's it's very obvious and
transparent we had nuke inrage on this
show last night uh Peter and and
yesterday he's now for the first time
only now convinced that he doesn't think
Joe is going to make it to November
because the cognitive decline of late
has been so steep do you see it you're
with them every day what do you
see well first of all greetings from the
bottom of a rabbit hole uh it's great
that we have connection down here to be
able to go live um but it is not a
conspiracy to ask questions about
mistakes the president makes considering
that uh it's not it it is not one person
saying this doesn't seem like it's right
it's three qus of those ped by NBC News
either have minor or major concerns
about his mental and physical health and
that includes half of Democrats and of
course everybody misspeaks from time to
time however not everybody is running to
be the president and not everybody is
running to be the oldest president ever
and so uh these things happen from time
to time uh there are very heavy issues
that whoever the president is next time
come January 2025 are going to have to
deal with and again it's three quars of
everybody pulled by NBC News
uh as to whether or not he's going to go
the distance this campaign we have no
reason to think that he's planning to
step aside if he does the plan is going
to be for the running mate KLA Harris to
ascend uh it you know you hear people
talking about oh well maybe there could
be something at the
convention there is nobody running a a
shadow campaign effective enough uh that
it would make sense for them to slide
somebody in there uh the last time we
really saw a prominent Democrat would be
uh on your show debating Ronda santis it
was Gavin Nome but but you don't hear as
much from him anymore well he's been out
campaigning for Joe Biden um def to my
mind defending the impossible in the
middle of my interview with with
Governor Nome at one point I just
stopped the interview I said here's your
problem
the guy that you are praising so much is
not capable of sitting here next to me
and having a conversation on this level
cuz he's simply not now when you compare
the hours that Donald Trump will devote
to interviews uh and he makes one
mistake boy if it's Pelosi and vice
president Harris and he mixes it up um
they're not taking into account all of
this I can't think of a single event and
you correct me if I'm wrong that Joe
Biden a clean event where he didn't have
cognitive struggles or you know
difficulty in in determining whether to
exit stage left or stage right cuz
that's now become a big problem I can't
think of a clean event can
you well the problem now is that they do
so little with him it really is just one
or two on camera events a week that
every word is so heavily scrutinized
when we first got on the Biden beat uh
back in the social distance days it was
like 10 reporters in the room with him
he wanted to talk after every single set
of prepared remarks that was three or
four times a week for 2 and 1/2 years
now it's three or four times a month at
best uh and and most of the time it's
when he is exiting the White House South
lawn exit uh to go on a marine one to
fly somewhere and it's you have to shout
at him and he's shouting back at you
because there's a an aircraft 100 feet
away
so that does seem to be stry in fact it
was another it was somebody in
this yeah but that that's the old Reagan
trick with Sam Donaldson Sam what Sam
good to see you can't hear you but you
know so other presidents have used the
the sound of a helicopter go
ahead well somebody in the second row at
the Press briefing today asked Karine
jeanpierre about why there's no Super
Bowl interview doesn't he want to have
this huge audience uh why has he done so
many fewer press events and PR
availabilities than his all of his
recent predecessors and she said I can't
deny the numbers uh that they are fewer
but he's going to try to get out there
in new ways and she mentioned radio
interviews and podcasts and social media
which have been used by Barack Obama
Donald Trump uh and Biden 2020 very
effectively so these are not new things
but they are basically telling us not to
expect to see or hear more from him
between now and November well I mean I
doubt he's going to be going on with uh
Charlamagne lagot again uh who's been
pretty critical lately as many others
have been he said nobody's actively
running a shadow campaign and I would
agree with you I don't think Gavin Nome
is doing that I mean he was very clear
that in his mind uh if you take him at
his word and I'll take him at his word
that kamla Harris would be next up
however does that negate the possibility
you keep hearing the name Michelle Obama
they go to Michelle Obama at the
convention will you you know take up the
mantle your country needs you is that is
is there that quiet Shadow campaign
maybe going on I've seen no evidence of
it I have no reason to believe she wants
to go back to Washington at
all I don't think she liked it the first
time
be I think that would probably be
optimism by like the 50s or so percent
of Democrats who are pulled by NBC who
think that Biden who are concerned that
Biden has mental or physical issues that
might be a problem for him in a second
term but from people that we hear from
that's not something that Michelle Obama
wants uh even though as we've seen in
the post presidency uh with just Book
Sales alone uh she is probably the most
popular Democrat
alive yeah it'll be interesting we'll
certainly be watching Peter thanks for
asking hey Sean Hannity here hey click
here to subscribe to Fox News YouTube
page and catch our hottest interviews
and most comp comping analysis you will
not get it anywhere
else